ich habe eigentlich ein
Gedankenexperiment normal was ich
angestellt habe ich habe gesagt stell
dich mal vor da gibt's jetzt junge Leute
die sagen unsere Migrationspolitik läuft
eine ganz falsche Richtung wir müssen
jetzt dringend was ändern hier gibt's
Riesenprobleme und die sagen dann wir
kleben uns jetzt fest auf den Straßen
wir blockieren wochenlang in der
Hauptstadt den Verkehr und wir verlangen
von der Regierung dass wenn die
Asylgesetzgebung nicht geändert wird ja
dann werden wir hier weiterhin alles
blockieren und ich möchte mal wissen wie
dann die Reaktion wäre dann wird sich
wahrscheinlich Frau Merkel wieder zu
Wort melden und Frau Käßmann wird sich
zu Wort melden und die ganze Republik
wäre empört und auch die Polizei würde
vermutlich in andere Weise dann
durchgreifen aber so
da war jetzt am letzten Sonntag eine
Diskussion im Presseclub da waren vier
Journalisten eine der hat gewirkt wie
der Pressesprecher von der Organisation
alles toll eine andere hat gemeint ja
auf der Straße festkleben ist gut aber
die Bilder beschrieben ist nicht so gut
da war nur einer überhaupt dagegen
gehalten hat ja und jetzt stelle ich mir
vor wie gesagt Gedankenexperiment jetzt
werden die Leute nicht links sondern die
werden rechts ja und dann stelle ich mir
vor was dann den ARD und ZDF und überall
in unserer Gesellschaft loswerden alle
würden laut aufschreiben und das ist für
mich einfach wieder ein Beispiel der
wird mit zweierlei Maß gemessen also ich
fasse das mal zusammen verstehe ich sie
da richtig dass sie eigentlich die
klimaaktivisten mit Extremisten
vergleichen also ich vergleiche nicht
sondern ich sage das ist eine Sekte ja
das weiß man auch aus allen Berichten
das ist eine Weltuntergang Sekt das
solche Sekten die gab es immer schon und
das ist hier eine Weltuntergang Sekte
die sind auch 16 organisiert die haben
sektenmäßig bestimmt Überzeugungen die
es gab es schon seit 100 Jahren immer
dass die Welt untergeht und das sind
natürlich viele dann auch vermengt sich
mit Antikapitalismus und so würde ich
dir auch bezeichnen ich finde auch diese
Bezeichnung Aktivisten das ist ärger
mich jeden Aktivisten lese also ich
schreibe konsequent in meinen Artikel
immer Weltuntergang Sekte weil genau
darum handelt
die Polizei wie sollte der Staat ähm
Vorgehen ihre Ansicht nach alles sollen
von dem Gesetz gleich sein das heißt der
muss natürlich die Gesetze angewandt
werden aber ich warne davor dass man
glaubt das Problem damit zu lösen im
Kern geht's hier um eine völlige
ideologische sagen wir
das Orientierung von großen Teilen der
Gesellschaft von den Grünen aber das
geht in alle Parteien hinein auch
letztlich ihre eigene Partei die Frau
Merkel hat ja diese Energiewende und
alles angetrieben was jetzt fortgesetzt
wird ja und das sind nur Leute das sind
extremer Form zur Ausdruck bringen ja
also wir werden das auf keinen Fall
jetzt primär oder allein mit Polizei
oder mit mit Gesetzen beseitigen können
sondern es geht um das dass wir eine
offensive geistige auseinandersetzen
brauchen mit der Ideologie die von
diesen Leuten vertreten wird und zwar
nicht nur von diesen Leuten sondern die
wird von den Grünen vertreten und das
geht praktisch mehr der mir natürlich
alle Parteien und Medien dürfen auf
jeden Fall das können wir festhalten
dass die Stimmung immer aufgeheizt wird
und das auch immer mehr Autofahrer zur
Selbstjustiz greifen schauen wir ja auf
die Bilder häufig hier aus Berlin
die Leute in Ruhe Leute
[Musik]
die Leute so lang zu reizen bis dann
solche Reaktionen kommen ja und dann
sind die Kamera Leute dabei und wenn
dann irgendwie eine ausrastet dann sind
sie natürlich eine Opferrolle drin und
das wird ja bewusst darauf angelegt die
Leute praktisch vollkommen zu entwerfen
und immer mehr Leute werden dann
entnervt und manche die Rasten dann halt
auch aus und das wird dann entsprechend
gefilmt verstehen sie die Wut der
Autofahrer die kann ich auf jeden Fall
verstehen
zum Ziel kommen auf der anderen Seite
ist es eigentlich auch verständlich für
die jungen Leute dass sie sagen wir
müssen etwas finden um die Klimapolitik
zu beschleunigen um die Klima Maßnahmen
effizienter zu machen und sie haben ja
echte Sorgen das ist ja nicht irgendwas
was die vorgehen und ich glaube nicht
dass die Spaß daran haben die Leute zu
provozieren ich glaube dass sie ehrlich
innerlich besorgt sind die haben nur
vergessen welche Möglichkeiten eine
Demokratie bietet gefährliche Sorge auch
umzusetzenden Aktivitäten in Veränderung
und die gehen natürlich die extremen
Schritte aus einer wirklichen Sorge
heraus aber ich kann natürlich nicht
verstehen dass man sowas tut das Gesetz
ist für alle da man kann nicht glauben
dass man über dem Gesetz steht und wer
das macht akzeptiert ja im Prinzip auch
das dass er ungesetzlich gehindert wird
an den Dingen die er glaubt äh
gesetzlich verändert zu werden ja was
ihr Verständnis anbelangt muss man ja
folgendes sagen wir haben in Deutschland
seit 1990 die CO2-Emissionen um 40 %
reduziert obwohl sich die Wirtschaft in
dieser Zeit verdoppelt hat das ist eine
gigantische Leistung und für jede
politische Maßnahme brauchen sie
Mehrheiten ich glaube nicht dass es eine
Mehrheit dafür gibt radikaler schneller
diesen Weg zu gehen weil das natürlich
auch mit entsprechenden
Wohlstandsverlusten und vielem anderen
mehr verbunden wäre und ja auch klar ist
dass das Weltklima in Deutschland nicht
alleine gerettet wird das heißt wir
werden dann erfolgreich sein wenn wir so
gut hinbekommen dass es andere in der
Welt uns nachmachen deutschland ist für
zwei Prozent des CO2-Ausstoßes
verantwortlich China für 28 Prozent das
soll kein abschieben von Verantwortung
sein aber es macht doch auch deutlich
dass wenn wir von zwei auf eins oder gar
null Prozent heruntergehen sich für das
Weltklima 0,0 verändern
viel gemacht vielleicht jetzt habt ihr
Ausreden dass es ausreichend und konnte
dir nicht mehr machen und wenn wir jetzt
nicht extremes tun dann werdet ihr
weiter euch auf euren Lorbeeren ja klar
aber das passiert ja gar nicht nein nein
nein die Politik mehr in die
Kommunikation um ehrlich zu sein ich
glaube das nicht natürlich in der
pluralen Gesellschaft wie wir sie haben
gibt es ganz unterschiedliche Meinungen
unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte das sind
übrigens auch legitim aber dafür sind
wir ein recht Staat dass das innerhalb
dieser Leitplanken zu funktionieren hat
wenn es Menschen gibt die sagen meine
Idee mein Ziel ist so viel wichtiger ich
kann mich von Recht und Gesetz nicht
aufhalten lassen dann muss man sagen
dann verabschiedet man sich aus dem
demokratischen Diskurs das ist nicht
akzeptabel denn wer soll denn darüber
entscheiden ob das eine jetzt ein
legitimes Interesse ist sie haben ein
Beispiel genannt in ihrem
Gedankenexperiment oder ob das ein
illegitimes Ziel ist das steht niemandem
zu da über andere zu richten so weit man
sich im Rahmen unserer Verfassung bewegt
wir haben jetzt gerade in den Bildern
auch gesehen dass die Stimmung immer
aufgeheizter wird bergsteigerlegende
erzählt man Reinhold Messner hat jetzt
sogar davon gesprochen wenn das so
weitergeht dann könnte sogar ein
Bürgerkrieg drohen stimmen Sie dazu
ja Bürgerkrieg sehe ich jetzt in
nächster Zeit nicht aber ich habe das
Interview auch gesehen hat von
Frankreich gesprochen als Beispiel ja
und natürlich was man in Frankreich
sieht da kann man sich schon Sorgen
machen jetzt sind wir ein bisschen
anders in der Hinsicht als die Franzosen
aber ich habe von der ganzen anderen
Sache Angst das nämlich
dass das wir immer mehr in eine falsche
Richtung laufen hier in Deutschland in
Richtung praktisch auf dem
Planwirtschaft und dass diese Leute
eigentlich nur wollen dass wir diesen
Weg der sowieso schon falsch ist noch
ein Stück schneller gehen das ist das
Problem und mit Planwirtschaft hat man
in den letzten 100 Jahren nie auf der
Welt irgendein Problem gelöst gerade
nicht im Umweltbereich sondern viele
Probleme erzeugt zum Beispiel die
CO2-Emissionen waren in der DDR dreimal
größer als in Westdeutschland wenn man
also aufs Bruttosozialprodukt bezieht
das heißt diese Lösung die die Leute
haben Kapitalismus abschaffen und
Richtung Planwirtschaft zum Beispiel
eine Ulrike Herrmann in ihrem Buch das
Ende des Kapitalismus das wird kein
einziges Problem lösen ganz bestimmt
nicht in der Umwelt und Klima so wird
viel größere Probleme machen und was
diese Leute fordern ist eigentlich nur
dass sie sagen der falsche Weg der in
Deutschland sowieso schon geht der
müsste jetzt noch viel schneller gehen
das ist die Forderung
draufgelegt und sagte die Frage des
Klimawandels die sei sowieso überschätzt
der Mensch habe gar nicht so viel
Einfluss glauben sie dass an diesem
Gedanke Wahrheit drin steckt naja in
jedem Fall ist es aus meiner Sicht
wissenschaftlich nicht bestreitbar dass
wir es mit einem menschengemachten
Klimawandel zu tun haben und deswegen
muss man eben auch den Ursachen auf den
Grund gehen und entsprechende
Gegenmaßnahmen ergreifen das passiert
seit vielen Jahren auf der Erde in
unterschiedlichen Tempo und
unterschiedlicher Geschwindigkeit aber
klar ist doch wir werden ja im weiteren
Verlauf vergleichbare Themen noch zu
behandeln haben dass das in der Tat
nicht mehr ordnete funktioniert das ist
nicht mit einer Verbotspolitik nicht mit
Ideologie funktioniert sondern dass man
dafür Mechanismen finden muss die auch
überzeugend sind Menschen müssen auch
überzeugt sein von der Richtigkeit
dessen was sie tun ansonsten werden
viele dem nicht folgen
so einseitig auf die Klimaforscher die
warnen und nicht auf andere sie sagen ja
auch Wissenschaft bedeutet eben immer
wieder sich zu überprüfen die Kinder die
andere Seite wird dazu sehr auf eine
Seite geachtet haben sie diesen Eindruck
ja ich beschäftige mich nicht so sehr
mit der Klimapolitik muss ich sagen da
bin ich viel zu sehr im
Durchschnittsbürger und mir geht es
eigentlich wie vielen anderen die
Atompolitik habe ich meine Meinung aber
habe ich die Ahnung davon mich da
wirklich Fach und sachkundigte
ich halte wird das für gut und richtig
anhalten dass die Bundesregierung auch
hier hilft den Menschen mehr
Informationen leichter zu bekommen um
sich sachkundig zu informieren
wir haben alle unsere Stammtische
Gespräche wir versuchen uns übers
Internet zu informieren aber ich glaube
die Bundesregierung nimmt ihre Aufgaben
nicht richtig war auch den Menschen zu
helfen die Sachkunde sich zu beschaffen
die Daten und Fakten leichter zu
Verfügung zu stellen auch die
gegenläufigen Meinung sicherlich in der
Presse kann man sich informieren da
gibt's immer die zwei Meinungen sich die
dargestellt werden aber ich glaube der
Information stand zur Klimapolitik ja
ist glaube ich nicht so ganz gut in
Deutschland da kann man fast auch so
eine parallel da kommen wir noch Eltern
der Sender dazu zu Corona ziehen also
inwiefern kann man sich auf die
Informationen verlassen wie wo soll man
sie herbekommen und wie gespalten ist
die Wissenschaft da auch manchmal was
glauben sie ist da die Aufgabe der
Wissenschaft ich habe mich auf viele der
auch öffentlich-rechtlichen Datenquellen
immer verlassen über viele Jahre als ich
im Ausland war und habe leider was ich
zu dem Thema wo ich wirklich Ahnung habe
Corona gemerkt dass da was von den
öffentlichen rechtlichen gesagt wurde
also sehr viel daneben lag und jetzt
frage ich mich selbst ist die Corona die
einzige das einzige Thema wo die da ab
und zu mal daneben liegen ja und das hat
natürlich auch höchstwahrscheinlich bei
anderen nie gewisse Skepsis äh indiziert
und ich habe diesen dieses Skepsis muss
man auch jetzt versuchen wieder was die
Leute wieder versuchen einzufangen und
das geht nur mit einer proaktiven
sauberen transparenten evidenzbasierten
Kommunikationspolitik man verliert sonst
die Leute und die Spaltungen in der
Gesellschaft kommt ja nicht irgendwoher
von innen die kommt eigentlich von außen
und die wird eigentlich glaube ich auch
durch diese Klimapolitik
projektbetrieben oder die Kommunikation
dazu und auf solche Aktionen wie die wie
die klimaaktivisten hier die wird ja
auch noch vertieft was glauben Sie Herr
Tackers wie tief ist diese Spaltung bei
diesem Thema schon vorangeschritten
ich glaube die Ursache liegt auch mehr
da drin dass heute die Bildung ja die
Social Media übernommen haben bei den
bei den Menschen ich glaube nicht dass
ein Großteil von denen die sich da auf
die Straße kleben ihnen erklären können
wie ein Gesetzgebungsverfahren in
Deutschland funktioniert oder wie ich
eine Partei Gründe um Interessen
durchzusetzen und zwar im demokratischen
Sinne die verlassen da tatsächlich unter
freier das ja deutlich angesprochen
meiner festen Überzeugung nach den
feierlich demokratischen Grund dabei und
für mich als ähm als als Exekutive also
als als einer der dafür sorgen muss das
Gesetz so umgesetzt werden für mich
stellt sich dann immer die Frage wie wie
sehr nimmt sich der Verfassungsschutz
dieser Thematik auch an wie sehr wird er
geschaut wie entwickelt sich da was was
kann man machen im punktu Bildung also
ich habe ja schon gesagt also wenn ich
mir drei Youtube Videos an guck wie
irgendwo die die Erde gerade zugrunde
geht dann wäre schon mal interessant
dass auch die Schulen im Rahmen ihrer
ihrer Bildung im Rahmen des Personals
der Lehrkräfte die da sind da mal wieder
das alles so ein bisschen gerade rücken
also ich glaube alle die wir hier sitzen
haben in der Schule noch
Wirtschaftspolitik oder
Staatsbürgerkunde oder sowas genossen
sicherlich die junge Generation auch auf
vermutlich nicht mehr so intensiv wie
heute weil heute eben Social Media da
eine große Rolle gespielt ich kann nur
immer sagen
Selbstjustiz darf es natürlich in
Deutschland nicht geben also das steht
ja völlig außer Frage ich habe aber auch
großes Verständnis für diejenigen die
jetzt vielleicht das dritte Mal in der
Woche zu spät zur Arbeit kommen oder
wichtige Termine verloren gehen weil
sich irgendwelche Chaoten ich nenne sie
auch Chaoten und Gottes Willen nicht
Aktivisten dort letztendlich in Berlin
auf die straßenkleber oder in Hamburg
oder München oder sonst wo und schlimmer
noch wir haben es ja auch in Berlin
Brandenburg am Flughafen gesehen da
tatsächlich in den empfindlichen
Sicherheitsbereich in den Flughafen
reingehen unter hunderte von Menschen
leben das jemand das ja gar nicht
vorstellen was passiert wäre wenn deine
Passagiermaschine gewesen also deshalb
sage ich natürlich auch wenn irgendwo
die Bildung fehlt dann muss Staat
trotzdem durchgreifen dürfen und zwar
konsequent durchgreifen dürfen weil
eines versteht ja versteht ja jeder
Mensch wenn ich was falsches mache und
das weh tut dann tue ich das nicht noch
mal zumindest nicht so schnell noch mal
und deshalb bin ich auch ein Verfechter
ich kann es noch mal wieder betont von
diesem Unterbindungsgewahrsam lange
genug hohe Haftstreifen früher handeln
die möchte nämlich dann handeln die
Kollegen werden auf der Straße was
passiert wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt das ist also eine
Verzehnfachung jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie